une photo pour l'histoire
l'Ukraine et l'Union européenne réunit
côte à côte à Kiev en pleine guerre
orsula vanderleyen s'est déplaçait avec
une délégation de commissaire européen
notamment se charger de l'économie
première annonce Bruxelles va fournir à
l'Ukraine une nouvelle aide de 9
milliards d'euros je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose c'est des prêts à très
long terme que l'Union européenne donne
mais il ne s'agit pas dans ce cas là de
reconstruction c'est pour tenir
l'économie de l'Ukraine en pied dans une
situation dramatique cet argent vise à
renforcer les secteurs clés de l'énergie
le gaz l'électricité mais aussi celui
des transports et l'agroalimentaire
sévèrement touché durant le conflit à
l'été 2022 le blocage dépend de la mer
Noire par l'armée russe avait provoqué
une flambée du cours du blé avant de
retrouver son niveau d'avant guerre
sur le plan militaire l'Union européenne
reste loin derrière les États-Unis en
matière d'envoi d'armée de munitions 30
milliards pour l'Allier américain contre
environ 15 milliards pour Bruxelles mais
sur la totalité des aides fourniaces
l'Union européenne se place en pôle
position avec près de 60 milliards
d'euros d'aide au total depuis le 24
février 2022 un partenariat plus
politique qui économique car l'Ukraine
n'est que le 17e partenaire commercial
du géant européen malgré ses aides
massives l'Ukraine aura besoin de bien
plus pour financer sa reconstruction
totale estimée aujourd'hui à environ 500
milliards de dollars